but welcome to the real world of doing
uranium chemistry you have to put lots
of gloves on to protect yourself
okay so dave has summoner's nitride
compound in this little vial which we've
kept stored in the fridge freezer in the
box just to make sure it's okay and it's
all under the atmosphere of nitrogen dry
nitrogen in this box to stop it going
off because it reacts with water and
oxygen which is in the air that you and
I breathe all the time
this is a paper we've just published and
we're pretty excited by this so this is
a uranium nitride which we've made and
if you're wondering what on earth one of
those is it's a compound with three
bonds between uranium and nitrogen and
this is quite an important compound
because it's taken literally decades to
make one and it was really quite tricky
but we got there in the end
so this has been published in an
American journal called science which is
published every week and it's a pretty
good journal to get published
pretty good you know that's that's Top
of the Pops isn't that yeah it is well
we started with this uranium molecule
just over here that this is a bit of a
boring structure to show you so I
thought I'd actually show you what it
really looks like looks like this well I
hope you can tell immediately when you
look at this is this is a really massive
molecule you almost cannot see the
uranium which is in this molecule and
it's this green sphere here that
represents the uranium atom it's sat
right in the middle of this structure
and there's lots of shrubbery around the
outside which is protecting that uranium
Center and this was really important for
making this nitride molecule because the
important thing about the way these
groups are wrapping around the uranium
is when you look from the top you can
sort of see there's a pocket just coming
in here and that means we can introduce
a group but basically stop it doing any
reactions with anything else in the
vicinity what we did is we took this
very simple molecule so this basically
is just a little ball and stick model of
what we call sodium azide and that's na
n 3 so three nitrogen atoms all in a row
and what's interesting about this
molecule is if you eject two electrons
into it you break one of the bonds I can
just demonstrate that by pop it's gone
and this fragment here that bond
then comes round and you've got your
triple bonds in nitrogen so that's n2
which is a gas which is about 70% of the
atmosphere we all breathe so that just
goes and what that leaves behind is a
nitrogen atom and a sodium and this now
carries a charge so it's very reactive
so it wants to bind to something and
some of you may have been thinking well
where did the electrons come from in the
first place well they came from the
uranium in the middle of this structure
so which means now it's positively
charged and this is negatively charged
so they're going to stick together
so this nitrogen and you can see this is
just fiddly to do we'll jump in there
now in reality the sodium isn't here
it's sort of up here somewhere but the
key point is this is a very reactive
nitrogen but it's got this sodium here
to help stabilize everything when you
make it so it kind of takes the sting
out of the situation just calms the
nitrogen atom down quite a lot and means
that you can isolate this molecule but
what we really wanted to do then was
pull that sodium away because then we'd
get this nitrogen with a terminal
linkage to the uranium and that's the
thing that everybody had being chained
chasing for decades so that the way we
did that is with a molecule called crown
ether so it's just like a big circle
going all the way around and there's
four oxygen atoms here shown in red and
this is what we call 12 crown for ether
and the four represents the fact that
there's four oxygens in this molecule
and when you kind of put it on its side
like this you can kind of see how it
looks a bit like a crown this little
sodium atom here that's not really to
scale for this crown here so I've just
mocked up a quick sodium cation which is
sort of comparable to the scale of the
crown but one of these crowns isn't
enough on its own so we have to bring in
a second crown to the equation and when
you add two of these you can see how
with one crown on the bottom
and a sodium cation stuck in the middle
and another crown on the top you end up
with the sodium completely trapped by
these two crown ether molecules so that
removes it completely away from the
uranium so there is those crayons came
in almost like a claw and grabbed it
away yeah they just do a smash and grab
and grab the sodium away and just keep
it nice and happy because it's got lots
of oxygen atoms bonded to it so what
you're left with now is our really
massive compound with that nitrogen atom
bonded to uranium and the key point is
because the nitrogen isn't bonded to
anything else and we know that nitrogen
usually likes to make three bonds to
other elements all those three bonds are
to the uranium so that's a un triple
bond so it's here so this is the
big-deal
yep so just those two atoms in that
structure they're the really important
bit but you need all of this other
shrubbery to stabilize it because it's
so reactive so Steve we've seen the
paper we've seen the moly mods can you
show me anything real absolutely come
this way hello okay so this is one of
the labs where some of my group are this
is Dave he's a PhD student he's the guy
that actually made this uranium nitride
molecule and now he's going to show you
actually it's in the glove box it's a
real kind of dark red color which is
actually quite sensible because the
uranium in this nitride it's what we
would call in oxidation state five and
uranium compounds with that oxidation
state tend to be very darkly and
intensely colored often red that's the
final molecule so that's the the massive
ligand with uranium and nitrogen in the
middle and then the sodium with 212 cram
four ethers as discrete pairs
in a crystal lattice it's been a good
three years trying to make this and a
lot of hard work and I'm just happy I
made it now so I don't have to go
through the process of making it again
how do you know that what's in that
parity is what he told me is in
development because we've analyzed it
with a huge variety of techniques each
one on its own would not be convincing
but when you bring them all together
it's absolutely incontrovertible that
the formulation is correct so that
compounds being analyzed by NMR infrared
spectrometry we've burned it to get
elemental percentages that are there in
the molecule we've looked at what's
called electronic absorption
spectroscopy we've looked at the
magnetic moment of the complex and we've
also I said it reacts with water when
you add water that nitrogen which is the
nitride turns into ammonia and we've
captured that ammonia and measured how
much of it we get to prove that that
nitrogen really is a nitrogen and then
to go one step further
we've isotopically labeled it so
nitrogen would normally have a mass of
14 we've also incorporated the mass of
15 isotope of nitrogen in there to prove
with various of the techniques that
probe the difference between the two
isotopes that it really is a nitrogen so
also we've done calculations to model
the structure and understand where the
electrons are so when you put all those
techniques together you really do get a
very good picture of what it is so yeah
that's all
here's a question for you Dave how much
do you reckon that pail is worth in
money too much um I don't know and
honestly couldn't tell you what about
the boss there what do you reckon that's
worth in money I think it's priceless